[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi la quête d'un meilleur
raisonnement a commencé avec la petite
souris
ma fille ça paye laffly elle a 9 ans on
est des plus petites
il croyait à la petite souris mais elle
a commencé à avoir des doutes quand la
perdu sa cinquième dans le lendemain
matin elle est arrivée au petit déjeuner
avec les pièces de deux euros de la
petite souris avec un regard très
suspicieux et nous a dit la petite
serait allé serment savait déjà puisque
c'est moi qui l'avais écrit j'ai pris
soin qu'ils ont fait pour l'écriture en
écrivant de la main gauche et la région
il ya un vote l'a écrit le d'en haut
lieu de l'avant
vous l'avez sans doute remarqué à molac
sentent le français n'est pas ma langue
maternelle et je vous fais un peu piégé
par ce dernier a conclu avec les entrées
enfants aucune seraient françaises leur
fessée c'est toi c'est toi la petite
sauver en matière de raisonnement des
enfants ne sut prennent souvent ils font
des liens des idées ils ont des idées
qui s'en venait de surgir de nulle part
voit en enfance ouvrions de la réflexion
ce que j'ai vécu ce maintenant avec
daphné est une des plus grande joie
d'être parents des études ont montré que
le bénéfice tiré dans meilleur
raisonnement peut être un aidant les
gens qui développe le raisonnement
critique ont plus de chances d'être
embauché d'être promu ils conduisent
plus prudemment
ils ont moins de risque de s'endetter
ses compétences ce raisonnement critique
pu donner l'impression devenu un as du
pain mais en rien n'était elle peut
s'épanouir que dans le bon environnement
avec le bon soutien avec la bonne
stimulation sellin nous les adultes
avons un rôle important à jouer pour
surmonter des problèmes que nous
rencontrons au niveau mondial novell
nous
tous besoin de raisonnement critique des
générations futures
cave être incapable de mettre de côté
leurs différences et leurs émotions pour
réfléchir plus clairement
c'est dans ce but que j'ai créé la
fondation qui finance des travaux de
chercheurs dans le domaine de réseaux
recrutés dans le monde entier viennent à
la suisse aujourd'hui je voudrais
partager avec vous trois grandes
enseignes mans de notre travail pour
aider des jeunes à mieux réfléchir
quel est le premier construire des bases
émotionnelles solide quand on parle de
raisonnement
en entendant ça envisager des processus
abstraite totalement déconnectés de la
vie courante on imagine les scientistes
dans leurs labos en train de faire des
expériences ou des mathématiciens du
vent à blois totalement déconnectés de
leurs émotions
la vérité c'est que même en raisonnement
plus haut niveau repose sur des bases
émotionnelles sli construite pendant
l'enfance un véritable réseau mot qui
tue qui peut sembler intellectuellement
éprouvant il est difficile et damien
émotionnellement ne demande en mélange
s'avère de confiance et d'humidité de ne
pas croire tout ce qu'on me dit mais de
ne pas rejeter tous les gens qui ne
pensent pas comme de nombreux en même
temps on doit être capable de gérer nos
émotions et de résister aux réactions
immédiates dans un guide de raisonnement
critique que notre fondation
buts a publié cette année nous montrant
comment des adultes peuvent cultiver ce
mix d'humilité et de confiance en les
encourageant à développer ses
compétences mais à l'intérieur d'un
cadre
ce dernier point est important des
enfants qui ont besoin autant de limites
que d'encouragement
je vais prendre un exemple personnel six
derniers mois on a regardé un
documentaire sur l' escalade et d'appui
souhaité essayer
nous n'allons pas leur ou est ce les
parades les braises en revanche je
promenais karting un but d' escalade
prévue chez nous c'est un projet
culturel que les lois il va rallier aux
activités à elles deux elles aussi ont
besoin du délit émotionnel des revenus
n'est pas prête à s'attaquer à pied
arrêtés mais nul encourageant
un lien est adoptée à l'essai du nouveau
concept hors de sa zone de confort ces
défis elle des enfants algériens des
émotions
ils apprennent interface à l'échec comme
au succès ils passent beaucoup concentré
sur ce qui peut contrôler peu à peu ils
vont tous que l'équilibré des nations
les tristes soit nécessaire pour le
raisonnement critique
revenons à chafni à la petit sourire n'a
pas beaucoup d'heureux
ce que moi les enfants dans sa classe a
essayé de la convaincre et s'est senti
suffisamment rowland est sûre d'elle
pour réfléchir manière critique et pour
arriver tout seul à la conclusion que
c'était des gens
le deuxième axe est terminée nos enfants
à réfléchir à leur magnan de dos ils
réfléchissent c'est que les chercheurs
appellent la bêta pro mission cette
prise de conscience nous permet de voir
nos propres limites et faire des efforts
pour améliorer nos arguments en allant
chercher des opinions opposées ce genre
de pensée réflexive est rare même parler
ce qui guide accordait beaucoup
d'importance dans une étude que la
fondation vivotait a mené la ligue et on
la regarde et on a fait mais tu pour
faire état des lieux du réseau mot
culture 97 % des gens interrogés ont
déclaré qu'ils ont considéré important
de voir des points de vue différents
dans les faits 25% des gens recherchent
jamais quand des gens qui pensent
différemment et 24% problème reconnu
d'éviter volontairement des gens qui ne
pensent pas comme elle
nous avons tous été témoins des dégâts
causés par l'obstination des gens qui
s'accrochent à leur point de vue et qui
refusent interagir avec des gens qui ne
pensent pas comme eux
vous connaissez tous le proverbe il ya
plus d imbéciles qui ne changent pas
d'avis mon expérience personnelle m'a
montré l'importance de point de vue
alternative donc non j'étais la seule
femme donc associé dans mon vestiaire
ils pensent mais concède invitation je
suis souvent la zone asiatique la scène
américaine d'avoir perspective habsheim
étrangers m'a beaucoup aidé à
reconnaître la pensée unique
bien sûr je me permets de temps en temps
deux êtres omd même moi même me laisser
entraîner par la pensée unique
mais je fais les formes pour vraiment
que quand tout le monde a l'air d'accord
de s'arrêter à réfléchir à notre malien
donc on est en train de réfléchir pour
développer ses habitudes mais la
commision chez les enfants nous pouvons
faire beaucoup
par exemple nous pouvons nous demander
comment est ce que tu sais ça qu'est ce
qui justifie cette hypothèse qu'on
expliquera tu cette idée à tisanes et
les papilles aussi poussé les enfants à
faire des expériences ils peuvent
essayer de faire des choses pas très
compliqué par exemple de faire goûter de
nouveaux aliments
même si parfois c'est très difficile
les enfants on les comprend qu'ils
apprécient quelque chose qui n'aimait
pas avant ils vont ils vont remettre en
question notre droit a priori
tout ça nous amène au troisième
enseignement disputons nous avec deux
enfants jeux l'extrait l'adolescence
vers 12 ans les enfants sont capables dû
résonner avec des concepts abstraits et
il peut faire des arguments beaucoup
plus complexe ils ont besoin de
pratiquer pour développer ses
compétences lui devons encourager les
enfants à exprimer leurs opinions
bien sûr au début lance des monts
paraître naïve grossier mais il ne faut
pas les rejeter il faut les encourager
il faut les prendre au sérieux
mais il ne faut pas non plus félicité à
bourgoin juste parce qu'ils ont émis un
avis plus on est à affiner leurs points
de vue qui sont tes propres
comment est ce que tu te rendre ton
argument encore plus fort pour faire une
eau à dos des citoyens avisés et éclairé
mutu vont les entraîner à identifier les
erreurs dans les arguments des autres et
dans les raccourcis fait par les hommes
politiques et les deux tiers aujourd'hui
du sanctus inondés d'informations
souvent y et z et parfois totalement
fausses il est donc vital que nous avons
des vélos des qualités
l'analyse d'informations d'évaluation
développement dès le plus jeune âge
plutôt que de terminer par un appel à
agir
je vous propose de terminer par un appel
à réfléchir dès demain améliorons le
réseau qui tue nos enfants
ça ne va pas être trop compliqué à
prendre de temps une simple conversation
ou petit exercice peuvent avoir des
effets durables
si vos enfants sont jeunes qu'est ce que
l'élève sur leurs centres d'intérêt et
trouver des moyens pour développer leur
estime de soi par la musique par le
sport par une exposition tournante
si vos enfants sont plus grands et lille
et à exposer leur point de vue ce
quelque chose qui est important pour
trouver en documentaire à regarder
ensemble et parlez-en ghz et un article
et analyser les arguments ensemble si on
donne aux enfants des occasions de
développer leur estime de soi de
réfléchir à leur manière
affichiste toi tu apprendras
argumentaire ils vont certes dafu mais
ne vont pas s'arrêter à la petite
semaine ils vont des masques et des
terrains bien plus dangereux
ils vont faire des observations peu plus
intéressant et là nous allons tous en
profiter merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]